okay we were talking yesterday about the
new haphazardly improvised Republican
healthcare bill and how it does not
guarantee protection to people with
pre-existing conditions but Donald Trump
says it does but Trump just seems
generally confused about what is and
isn't in the bill but enough about Trump
let's talk about u.s. congressman from
Alabama Alabama mo Brooks a member of
the house freedom caucus he has an
interesting take on this entire
pre-existing conditions issue and it's
sort of complicated he's against the
bill but he said some things yesterday
when talking about pre-existing
conditions that are really confusing to
many people so let's just watch it
together first and then see if we can
make heads or tails out of it
in an interview President Trump said
that people with pre-existing conditions
will be protected insurance companies
will not allow not be allowed to deny
them coverage but my understanding is as
you just mentioned this new legislation
would allow states to opt out and allow
insurance companies to refuse to sell
insurance to people with pre-existing
conditions as long as there's some with
some setup for them
pools of some sort is the president
sending a message to Congress to change
that provision or did he not understand
what was in the bill well that's not my
understanding of the way the bill has
been reframed my understanding is that
it will allow insurance companies to
require people who have higher health
care costs to contribute more to the
insurance pool that helps offset all
these costs thereby reducing the cost to
those people who lead good lives they're
healthy
you know they've done the things to keep
their bodies healthy and right now those
are the people who've done things the
right way that are seeing their cost
skyrocketing now in fairness a lot of
these people with pre-existing
conditions they have those because those
conditions through no fault of their own
so he makes this caveat at the end
saying some of these people have
conditions through no fault of their own
and yes it's true that individual
behaviors can lead to certain medical
conditions but what's completely ignored
here there's a couple things ignored
here and I don't even know where to
start focusing in on this thing number
one whether or not you lead a good life
and do the right things
it doesn't just have to do with your
desires there are completely intractable
financial situations which lead to
poorer health outcomes people live in
food deserts people can't afford fresh
produce and instead they're eating
frozen dinners all the time or whatever
the case may be this idea that although
there are some people who did the right
thing and still got sick if you lead a
good life you avoid ending up with a
pre-existing condition it ignores
fundamental realities about what it's
like to live in the United States of
America and also as to what the role of
government should be because if we can't
address something as basic as Public
Health that yeah what other priorities
are ahead of that absolutely it's what
when we look at how we deal with the
issue of health insurance and healthcare
versus how other countries at our level
of development do it it makes what mo
Brooks is saying particularly off-base
now he's against the bill and I am
against the bill so okay there's there's
some sort of common ground there but
again we're getting into this issue of
well are we Obamacare had this provision
where you can't charge people way more
when they have pre-existing conditions
or deny them coverage our Republicans
going to include that provision that's
only layer one because if you include
the provision but then allow a waiver to
get out of it it's sort of a way to just
pander to both sides without really
making it so that people with
pre-existing conditions are protected
and as a member of the house freedom
caucus I think it's fair to assume that
mo Brooks is against the pre-existing
condition provision I'm sure that if he
had someone in his own family who
suffered from you know Crohn's disease
or cancer or one of these pre-existing
conditions that he would change his tune
probably you know we've seen that happen
with some Republicans and and others
take a sort of pseudo principled stance
where they say whatever my family's
condition this is sort of libel what I
believe in what's getting lost in this
entire thing is we're forgetting the
whole point of insurance and how
insurance works and the idea that in
order to have a risk pool that is spread
out and is not subject to big swings
based on the activities of some small
portion of the people in the risk pool
the risk pool needs to be as big as
possible and it can't
exclude certain people this is the whole
point of insurance and you know I don't
know ultimately where this is going to
go but serious sort of confusion is to
leading a good life and who decides if
you've led a good life if we can't even
agree on what the food pyramid should
look like it changes every two years and
objectively speaking low Brooks is
saying hey if you lead a good life with
some exceptions you're not going to end
up with a pre-existing condition so
discuss this with us on our reddit
discussion forum the American Health
Care Act and the new iteration of this
entire thing is generating a lot of
discussion you can find that at david
pakman.com slash reddit today's episode
is supported by taga dabbe the hosting
specialists they offer dedicated VPS and
cloud server options they have a
fantastic team of expert hosting
specialists it's also a friendly support
team it's a team that gives customers
access to the full knowledge and service
that they're able to provide and 70% of
their business actually comes in from
repeat orders and recommendations from
existing customers they have a
Trustpilot review rating of excellent at
nine point seven out of ten there's more
and more people interested in moving
their businesses and projects to the
cloud and taga dab is currently offering
a ten-pound free credit to all new
customers signing up to give you a
chance to try the service and to take
advantage of this you merely go to sign
up CagA deb comm /td PS that sign up dot
ta ga DAV comm /t dps